Mac's career 15 games 13 starts against
the Dodgers good ERA and he's five and
five against them
that starter goes with the five pitch
mix fastball cutter slider curveball and
good change up
one tutumuki
this one is ripped inside a third a fair
ball
that's going to go down toward the
corner and Loki bets will pull in the
second base where there's 21st double of
the Season he's fifth in the National
League in doubles
this one to Center Road Blaze has to
reach up high for it he's going to pull
it to Third and it's a double play well
for a moment there I thought Victor was
burnt but he got a great breed on this
one charging in
clearly Lukey bets has not been watching
the highlights of Victor Road West throw
from center field because he's got an
absolute Cannon
perfect throw right on the money no
argument from mookie as he headed right
to The Dugout
huge play for the Nats
Trey enemies
Leo Urias makes his 17th start second in
wins behind Kyle Hendricks of the Cubs
of course Clayton Kershaw tied with
Julio with nine wins also
the 1-2 he Strikes Out Swinging slider
down and in one two oh got him with a
good breaking ball two up two down two
strikeouts for Julio Urias
he did pretty often yeah Zimmerman pops
it up right side coming in as bets
okay with the cats
oh change up on O2 to a right-handed
batter Max track out number 121 and his
second tonight and the pitch swung on
into the air to left Center roll place
across and now angling back a bit makes
the catch in left center for the outs
swinging a Miss on a nasty slider
there it goes a long one to let from
Gomes it's gonna one hop at the wall
Castro for third Jan Gomes to second on
an absolute rocket
and here's Victor Robles with Runners on
second and third
Robles pulls it ball hugging the line
Fair Turner throws it away a one scores
Bob Henley is going to send Gold's home
he is safe into third Victory Robles
it's a little league triple in the Nets
lead two nothing
artiaga out to Center
great speed at third Bellinger all he
can do is fling it home no chance
three-nothing Nationals here's Kyle
schwarber he struck out swinging his
first time out here's the set the pitch
swung online in the right center that's
a base hit off the fastball Ballinger
plays there right center schwarber he'll
hold up and she's overheard himself
rounding first base absolutely did it
grabbed on him as he rounded the bag it
looks like he's grabbing the back of the
right leg in the right hamstring Kyle
schwarber is going to walk out of this
game look like he turned his ankle first
and did that lint then lead to the
hamstring pull potentially oh
foreign to the left side right there
Gavin Lux
close at first as solo can run Castro on
Deck urius delivers and Zimmerman pops
this one up to the right side second
baseman Chris Taylor's underneath that
makes a catch and there's two guys
Trail hits one deep two right center
field Bellinger on the track has it
lined up Justin Turner who's single left
in his first at-bat Shares are delivered
there is a Fly ball a fairly deep center
field way back and it is gone a home run
Justin Turner goes the other way two for
two on the day against Scherzer his 13th
home run of the season the Dodgers are
on the board but the Nationals still
lead it 3-1
foul tip on the fastball and the striker
front door on the curveball
and that is unhittable
77 Sunset Strip on the curveball he
starts the wind up over the head the
kick in the pitch swinging a mess he
struck him out with a slider
here it comes swinging a high pop-up
shallow left Arteaga racing out Robles
tearing in artiaga can't see it he goes
down into a Crouch but fortunately
Robles does and makes the catch long
hold the 2-2 swingers poked in the air
shallow right out goes Harrison Soto
it's his ball coming in toward the line
he'll make the catch
another pop-up
where's the ball it's somewhere on the
infield
and it's in the glove
Friday Saturday
however many other days you can figure
out but it's less fires on to First a
little high but Max handles it and
Zimmerman is out six to three well
Julio's 2-1
on the ground down to Turner he goes to
Second for one on to first that's a
double play around the horn to end the
inning
[Music]
foreign
the air to right center and deep that's
going to go off the base of the wall
and Taylor in the second base with a
lead off double
Taylor to third with one out and Here
Comes Who holds
well bouncer slowly hit
and it's dropped Tanner scores it's
three to two the Dodgers are hitting 3
47 with the bases loaded this year and
here's mookie bets
there's a shot to left field and a base
hit Pujols will score and coming in is
Barnes and the Dodgers have taken a lead
it's four to three Los Angeles and the
Nationals bring the infield in the 1-2
Muncie
pokes A Little Blooper into short left
field for a base hit mckinstry comes in
to score and so does bets and now
suddenly the Dodgers have themselves a
6-3 lead
this one in the right center that's down
for a hit
Turner scores Here Comes Bellinger into
score it's eight to three Pollock pinch
hitting began the inning and this is his
second at Battle already
to Right Center it is gone a home run
A.J Pollock his second home run in his
many games and the Dodgers are pouring
it on here in the seventh
Zimmerman hard hit right side it eats up
Muncie coming around to score Harrison
Soto to Third
and Ryan Zimmerman checks in most
probably well we'll see what the score
decides the ball has really hit hard and
the bases are loaded for young Gomes
pace is loaded one down payoff little
bouncing ball towards short grabbed by
Taylor there's one there's two got the
double play he wanted
Apple true
and dropped by Cody Bellinger
that's on the board it's ten to five
Harrison bounces it towards short
charging as Taylor and that's your ball
game and the Dodgers have won seven
straight